One of the hardest questions when you think
about the evolution of the human species,
from the standard framework of evolution,
which really is about individual survival,
competing, getting your genes to the next
generation -- one of the hardest questions
within that framework is why are people so
frequently and routinely good and generous
and sacrificing, right?
And you know, most people think that Darwin
had this idea of "survival of the fittest"
that really it's the most ruthless and bloodthirsty
who really thrive and survive.
That is not Darwin's view of human evolution
at all he really felt that sympathy is the
strongest instinct that human's have.
Communities that have the most sympathetic
members will flourish and raise the greatest
number of offspring.
That notion of Darwin's led to this sense
that out of the vulnerability of our offspring
emerged, first of all social structures like
cooperative care giving and then also physiological
systems shaped by evolution to help take care
of the carriers of our genes:our offspring.
We have learned from neuroscience down at
UCLA that if you feel physical pain, a part
of your brain lights up and if I see you have
that physical pain, the same part of my brain
lights up.
It's as if we're wired to have the same experience
of other people.
Empathy is this really complicated task.
It really engages the frontal lobes, these
newer regions of the cortex that are involved
in more complex symbolic processes like language
and imagining the future.
Because empathy requires that you think: there's
someone else out there who has feelings and
thoughts that may be different from mine -- that's
a really complicated cognitive achievement.
In my lab, the Berkeley social interaction
lab, we showed images of prototypical suffering
to our participants.
They trigger massively powerful reactions
of compassion and what we found in the brain
is that a very old part of the brain called
the periaqueductal gray, which is common to
mammals when they take care of things, lights
up when you feel compassion.
So that tells us, compassion is really old
in the nervous system as Darwin speculated.
My students and I got really interested in
social class.
What does it do to the human mind?
Our lab and other labs are interested in something
called the vagus nerve.
It's the longest bundle of nerves in the human
nervous system.
In our research compassion, the feeling of
caring for someone in need, activates the
vagus nerve.
Lower class individuals, if we show them images
of suffering, they have a vagus nerve response.
You don't see that in upper class individuals.
It literally is a compassion deficit that's
produced by lots of wealth.
Next set of studies on charity: who gives?
Economic analyses would say if I have a lot
of money, it should be easy to give.
If I have 900 bucks in my bank account, giving
away money -- it really matters, you know,
it matters what you put in your fridge.
And in spite of that what we find is lower
class individuals give more, and this is replicated
in studies of philanthropy.
You know one of things this science tells
us is there is enormous strength in these
poorer communities of generosity and empathy
that you know, many people in more privileged
circumstances miss -- it's strong community.
Yeah, you know 60 percent of what we do is
really about maximizing an individual's personal
gratification and desire, just the classic
survival of the most competitive -- but 40
percent of the time, we're really doing things
for other people and we sacrifice and we risk
exploitation and we still do it.
And not only that but, it actually becomes
personally fulfilling and inspiring to engage
in that work, we find these secondary delights
in enacting on behalf of others.
And I think that it really requires that we
redefine human self-interest.
You know, the great ethical traditions have
always been encouraging this and now we're
seeing the science say, yeah that brain really
cares about other people.